poursuivons avec l'article 22 trois
amendements identiques le 83 c'est
monsieur savoldelli ou la présidente à
ça si ce volet merci monsieur le
président j'ai mis ce mets mes chers
collègues nous pouvons supprimer c'est
cet article qui ouvre un cadre juridique
l usage des drones cet article 22 ans
carl usage des caméras disposées sur les
drones afin de veiller au respect de
l'ordre public et soutient l'action des
forces de l'ordre opération la collègue
d'image par les drones serait autorisée
par cet article y compris on se demande
si c'est pas l'objectif voulu y compris
lors de manifestations sur la voie
publique
bien que cet article ait été réécrit en
partie par la commission et a dû un
travail déjà de vigilance d' alerte
il nous semble qu'ils noueraient il
reste quand même dangereux puisqu'il en
cas d' usage des caméras disposées sur
les drones afin de veiller au respect de
l'ordre public et à soutenir l'action
des forces de l'ordre en opération la
collègue d'image par des drones est
autorisé par cet article y compris lors
de manifestations même si l'article
précise que les personnes qui sont
surveillés par drones en seront informés
alors là si vraiment monsieur le
ministre vous nous donner les garanties
que toutes celles et tous ceux qui vont
être visionnées par les caméras des
drones vont être informés peut-être
qu'on peut retirer l'amendement
parce que je vous ai écouté vous êtes un
fin technicien de l'image de la
communication
voilà où expliqué que les drones qui
vont circuler lors des manifs vont
quasiment mécaniquement informer ceux
qui vont être visionné ce qui doit
m'arriver assez souvent
vous le comprenez mais on va être
informé bon je vous avoue que la satire
pas trop la route
à mon avis comme argument et s'agissant
de la quadrature du net dans son analyse
de proposition de loi ils le disent que
les personnes surveillées par drones ou
caméra mobile ne pourront pas être
véritablement informés et c'est quand
même une exigence de la constitution
monsieur le ministre
et puis puisqu'il faut en rajouter une
couche au millefeuille ce aussi celle du
droit européen
donc vous demandons de faire preuve de
sagesse et de responsabilité et de
supprimer cet article
merci l'amendement sans mal à mettre
basse a défendu il défendu
le 200 296 pardon merci monsieur le
président également cette cet amendement
propose de supprimer l'article 22 qui en
apparence semble être une dispositions
utiles en effet l'article 22 il vient
vient combler un vide juridique en
proposant de définir le cadre légal
l'utilisation des caméras est reporté
d'ailleurs la nécessité d'inscrire dans
l'eau droit régime dédiés à
l'utilisation de cette technologie
s'imposer d'autant plus que le conseil
d'état avait pointé une atteinte grave
et manifestement illégale au droit au
respect de la vie privée à l'occasion
son utilisation dans les forces de
sécurité néanmoins il apporte des
garanties insuffisantes
en dépit des modifications qui ont été
apportées par la commission des lois que
ce soit l'interdiction de la captation
des sons la reconnaissance faciale ou
des interconnexions automatisé de
données
les garanties censées assurer le respect
de la vie privée sont insuffisantes et
inapproprié en effet l'article 22 ne
précise pas comment il sera possible de
rendre compatibles usage des drones avec
la condition impérative de ne pas
visualiser les images de l'intérieur des
domiciles et leur entrée deuxièmement
les modalités de l'information du public
ne sont pas précisés
sauf à se satisfaire de la formulation
par tout moyen approprié
en outre ces propositions sont
aléatoires car elle se trouve
conditionné par des réserves qui les
rendront le plus souvent inapplicables
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet la commission
des lois n'a pas apporté de n'a pas
apporté de réponse n'est pas acceptable
que le parlement ne se prononce pas sur
cette condition minimale en se
déchargeant sur le pouvoir réglementaire
par renvoi au décret d'application
le périmètre lui servant de support et
trollage en raison de la multiplicité de
la diversité des motifs susceptibles
d'être invoquée pour justifier le
recours aux drones à des fins de
captation et d'enregistrement à cet
égard la mobilisation des caméras et
reporter notamment pour l'encadrement
des manifestations ne va pas sans
soulever de fortes craintes sur le
risque d'atteinte au droit de manifester
enfin on ne peut traiter de ce sujet
dans le cadre d'une simple non
clairement aig
il est donc c'est pourquoi je vous
propose de retirer cet article merci le
296 monsieur durand à cette évasion et
ses causes et ses 296 parle on est donc
sur les trois amendements identiques
monsieur le rapporteur bien monsieur le
président que je mets ce cher collègue
bon on peut avoir ce débat à devenir une
manière liminaires et se dire que
finalement en restant au droit actuel ne
créons pas alors que la cnil conseil
d'état l'exigent une base juridique pour
l'utilisation des drones et on interdit
l'utilisation des drones c'est ça c'est
l'objectif c'est ça ça veut dire que les
appareils qui ont déjà été acquis seront
revendus sur ebay où notre plate forme
de votre choix
et puis on n'utilisera plus hydro en
montagne pour aller sauver des personnes
et puis on les utilisera plus à de très
nombreuses utilités qui sont pourtant
qui sont pourtant utile et qui met la
technologie au service des forces au
service de la sécurité des forces mais
aussi au service de la sécurité des
citoyens et moi je n'ai pas avec la
commission nous n'avons pas retenu cette
vision là et nous pensons que il faut
donner comme nicolas dhuicq député
monsieur le ministre un cadre juridique
qui soit robuste mais qui permettre qui
permettent d'utiliser ces drones dont
cadre est aussi les évolutions
technologiques qui ne manqueront pas
d'arriver dans les années qui viennent
et de les mettre au service de
de nos forces le progrès technique en
soit c'est pas à vous je vais devoir le
dire
brian is en soit il est là aussi pour
rendre plus faciles plus simples un
certain nombre de missions y compris des
missions de service public et donc moi
je ne peux rendre un avis défavorable et
vous inviter à proposer des amendements
de 2 me de complément à ce que nous
avons fait au sein de la commission des
lois
ce que certains d'entre eux n'ont pas
manqué de surrey ce qui va nous occuper
une partie encore de de ce2 et nuit mais
voilà à 8,3 avis défavorable monsieur le
président merci à monsieur ministre
excellent le président de ce rapporteur
sur la nécessité de légiférer et sur
pourquoi on prend cet article 22 je vais
répondre à monsieur le sénateur
puisqu'il même promis un défi mais ici
vous arrivez expliquer comment on peut
être filmé par ado je retire mon
amendement bon bah en général une
manifestation avait déclaré et quand
elle déclare il ya un parcours il est
tout à fait envisageable de mettre des
panneaux d'information pour bonjour
cette manifestation et vidéosurveillées
est surveillé par drones
c'est le cas aujourd'hui dans les
communes pour entrer dans une commune ya
des panneaux et marquer vous êtes
dans une ville qui met des caméras de
vidéoprotection et on vous explique
comment récupérer les images si vous
souhaitez consulter votre droit à
l'image les manifestations par ailleurs
quand elles sont en place sont pas dans
des communes où dans des départements on
est d'accord manifesta pas arriver ni
festhéa tourcoing on pourrait tout à
fait imaginer que l'obligation
d'information ça sur le site de la
préfecture du lieu de département où il
ya la manifestation par exemple
manifestation de l'est parti communiste
français à tourcoing sur le site de la
ville de tourcoing c'est la préfecture
de tourcoing de nord par exemple
manifestation cette manifestation
autorisée sera vidéo protégés par drones
ça fait imaginer que ce soit également
sur internet
donc il ya plein de façons d'informer la
personne et qui est concerné tout à fait
donc je vois pas en quoi c'est
incompatible bien au contraire
et puis troisièmement il ya des pays
puisque il faut quand même savoir que
tous les pays européens utilisent ces
drones tous tous tous les pays
occidentaux utilisent ces drones pas
avec les mêmes cadres légaux que nous
d'ailleurs parfois sans base légale et
c'est ce qu'a rapporté me sera porteur
et dans certains pays même
il ya même une information vocal au
début au milieu à la fin la
manifestation par exemple donc il ya
plusieurs moyens d'informer les
personnes qui sont effectivement vidéo
pardo vidéosurveillées vidéo protégés
par drones et donc je crois monsieur le
sénateur qu'il serait bon que vous
teniez votre pari et vous retirer votre
amendement
merci monsieur ben asher merci monsieur
le président monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues dans je crois que si on
veut protéger moi je me battrai toujours
pour protéger les manifestants dans leur
liberté constitutionnelle
il faut pouvoir repérer ceux qui
viennent
débordée ces manifestations et il ya des
équipements modernes
il faut pouvoir les utiliser dans un
cadre contrôlé et ce serait donc
peut-être une erreur peut-être
voilà mon opinion une erreur que de ne
pas légiférer tels que loïc hervé vient
le rappeler il y à une demande mais s'il
vient pour protéger les manifestants
qu'ils manifestaient pacifiquement
aujourd'hui des manifestations et ayons
un peu de mémoire
combien d'assemblée ont été attaqués
lors de certaines manifestations dit le
gilet jaune dit j ai jaune l'assemblée
nationale le sénat aussi ils sont passés
tout près souvenez vous c'était un
samedi
nous avons été alors que nous discutions
des lois de finances confiné ici
souvenez vous de cela souvenez-vous des
black blocks il faut trouver aujourd'hui
des moyens modernes de lutter contre
ceux qui ont des moyens modernes aussi
de vouloir casser la démocratie alors
contrôlant la noue gardien des libertés
légiférons proprement tel que l'a dit
loïc hervé et le ministre si monsieur la
mairie oui merci monsieur le président
on se munit chocolat très rapidement
simplement pour comprendre les mots ces
amendements mais supprimer cet article
22 et quand on prend connaissance du
rapport de la commission des lourds
notamment concernant cet article 22
support personnellement spécialiste des
drones mais je dirais quand on lit le le
rapport de la commission c'est bien
indiqué sur cet article 22 lusage des
des caméras embarquées sur sur les
drones
pour des usages multiples variées et on
le voit aussi pour malheureusement de
reconstituer dans le cadre de
reconstitution d'accidents graves de
lutte contre les catastrophes naturelles
sécurité des personnes sécurité des
biens
donc aussi des usages quand même qu'ils
sont indispensables dans le cadre de
l'utilisation de ces techniques dont je
pense que la tour aussi des décades de
manifestations autres d'ordre public
autres on va je pense que là il y va
quand même dû de l'intérêt général et je
pense que il faut pas non plus voir le
mal partout faut aussi faire confiance
et essayer de progresser voilà donc
gérer dans le sens de la commission des
lourds merci chers collègues manager
italien
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues
monsieur le ministre au début de cette
discussion vous disiez on dit que le
gouvernement se rapprochent d'orwell
mais nous nous sommes des libéraux nous
nous rapprochons plutôt de tocqueville
est le problème je crois qu'aujourd'hui
c'est que le libéralisme a de plus en
plus de difficultés à assumer sa facette
des libertés individuelles et qu'ils se
resserrent qu'il se restreint de plus en
plus sur une vision très très libérale
uniquement du point de vue économique et
que ce système économique conduit à
tellement d'inégalités tellement de
souffrances tellement d'injustices et de
sentiment d'injustice pas seulement de
sentiment d'injustice un tailleur mais
d'injustice réel et ben oui qu'il ya des
mouvements sociaux des contestations et
je crois que le nouveau monde que nous
vivons depuis 2010 est c'est justement
finalement la vision de ce libéralisme
étriqué au libéralisme économique et une
certaine vision orwellienne et nous le
voyons dans cette proposition
loi et nous le voyons dans ces
restrictions des libertés et notamment
dans cette proposition est d'ailleurs si
c'était qu'une proposition dans les
faits déjà dans un certain nombre de
manifestations avec l'utilisation de ces
drones et l'utilisation aussi de cette
fameuse neuf langues dont parlait orwell
car quand j'entends que les
manifestations vont être vidéoprotégé va
écouter ça me fait ça me ferait rire si
seulement je ne me sentais pas de moins
en moins protégés dans les
manifestations par un certain nombre de
pratiques gaz lacrymogènes à tous à tous
à tout coin de rue système de nas de
quel on peut plus sortir d'une
manifestation alors excusez-moi je crois
qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation où nous le notons le droit de
manifester est battue en brèche
et oui beaucoup de françaises et de
français hésitent à venir manifester
parce que maintenant ça leur fait peur
mais c'est pas seulement parce qu'il ya
des black blocks je ne nie pas qu'il y
en ait mais c'est aussi parce qu'il y
avait un sentiment d' escalade
d'escaladé y compris dans la façon dont
le maintien de l'ordre et mis en oeuvre
et ce n'est plus du maintien de l'ordre
je crois malheureusement auquel nous
assistons mais à une escalade dans le
désordre
donc oui c'est cette utilisation sept
procès propositions d'utilisation de
drones vont à l'encontre de la liberté
de manifester sa a été noté noté est
dénoncée notamment par des organismes
institutionnels comme la cncdh
et je crois qu'il faut s'y opposer
fermement ces chers collègues monsieur
durand
oui je prendrai pas le même point de
départ que ma collègue sophie taille et
polluant mais si on s'intéresse un peu
au regard qui a été porté sur la
disposition relative aux drones
elle est quand même
accueillis avec beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de réserves cncdh conseil
d'état défenseur des droits et
d'ailleurs si on se dit les choses
jusqu'au bout entre nous il ya deux
usages des drones ya le maintien de
l'ordre
et il ya tout le reste est l'essentiel
des arguments qu'on a développé ce soir
concerne le maintien de l'ordre
moi je suis pas persuadé comme le disait
le ministre tout à l'heure que
l'obligation d'information elle soit si
facile à mettre en oeuvre
si j'en étais convaincu j'aurais presque
pris le même pari que le comex à lever
délit mais je pense que ça n'est pas
possible
par ailleurs je pense que quand on voit
ce que dit le sm aussi un qui est un des
interlocuteurs qu'on a eu pendant ses
auditions sur la très grande latitude
qui est laissée aux forces de sécurité
intérieure pour l'usagé des drones
on se plaît à penser quand même que le
saut technologique et la capacité de
captation d'image la facilité
d'utilisation que représente le drone
change quand même le paradigme des
images dans le master de langues
principalement c'est vrai que si on
avait été plus rassurés sur ces sujets
là avec des garanties plus sérieuse plus
celui de plus robuste peut-être qu'on
aurait apprécié c'est l'ensemble de cet
article 22 avec d'autres arguments
merci cher collègue monsieur sa volée
mais merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
trois observations
la première les exemples vous avez pris
oui telles organisations politiques
syndicales associatives déclarant
préfecture une manifestation elle a la
responsabilité de la manifestation avec
les drones c'est pas la question qui se
pose c'est une question de libertés
individuelles
tout individu femme homme peut
participer à une manifestation sans se
reconnaître de l'identité de celui
qu'elle organise la manifestation
non y'a pas d'étiquette ya pas ça marche
pas comme ça il n'y a pas la manif du
pcf la manif des républiques à la manif
des verts du ps et cetera excusez moi la
majorité des français n'ont pas
d'étiquette politique une appartenance
politique et l'appartenance syndicale
etc et ils ont droit de vouloir
conserver leur liberté
ça c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose sur le ministre on va pas faire
nous nos états de deux buts engagement
mais c'était avant votre gouvernement
j'ai fait les manifestations sur le web
comme rri j'en ai fait d'autres et
d'autres ont pu vérifier la même chose
que moi me vendait pas les drones pour
les black blocks
j'ai vu du laxisme j'avais pas besoin
des drones pour identifier des pratiques
d identité vestimentaire comportementale
de pratique était hors du champ de
l'intérêt de la manifestation et mon
problème c'était pas les drones s'était
d'isoler ceux qui n'avaient rien à faire
avec cette manifestation et ça c'est pas
une question de drones ça c'est une
question de volonté politique
la troisième chose que je veux vous dire
c'est que ça vous plaît pas mais bon
voilà après c'est mon expérience
excusez moi mais la cnil elle a quand
même transmis à la commission des lois
du sénat que l' usage de drogue est
dangereux et sur un autre critère que la
question des libertés
donc ça vaut le coup d'être examinée
donc on peut pas d'un revers de main
balancer tous les arguments qui viennent
ici dans l'hémicycle ils ont raison il
ya des compétences et des savoirs ils
sont inquiets sur la minute ya la mini
itx érosion et les capacités techniques
des drones donc ça vaut le coup quand
même d'y réfléchir quand même de ce
point de vue là et pas balayer en disant
voilà avec des histoires et des récits
ici ou là il ya telle manifestation
organisée etc
on en train d'organiser la société ici
soir ou ce matin
donc voilà c'est c'est quand même
quelque chose de sérieux
de ce point de vue là merci reconnaît
monsieur grand monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
chaque collègue nous nous vivons là un
moment assez exceptionnel d'abord je
suis très heureux de voir que notre
collègue à l'instant finalement regrette
l'époque où le parti communiste était
suffisamment fort suffisamment puissant
pour pouvoir organiser les
manifestations et les encadrer comme
nous savons finalement on peut se
rejoindre en revanche
qu'est ce que vous voyez chers collègues
finalement les manifestations cent
policiers sans bronn sans caméra paix ce
n'est plus possible
les manifestations ont changé de nature
les militants qui défilent sont violents
et les blagues gorgui sow qui se rajoute
aux militants violents sont encore plus
violent et donc ça donne quoi
eh ben ça donne de la violence et à la
violence il faut répondre il faut que la
démocratie et la république réponde et
naturellement et naturellement les
drones 1 et via les drones y sert
effectivement à réguler les choses et à
donner des indications sur ce qui se
passe ça me paraît pas attentatoire
démocratie et surtout si on regarde tous
les pays européens toutes les
démocraties et bell font pareil
les démocraties elles se défendent parce
que ceux qui cassent ce sont pas des
démocrates se sont pas des républicains
est ici on est là pour répondre défendre
la république
merci chers collègues m'avaient
présidente assassi puis ensuite on passe
au vote
je suis désolé il y a encore ce soir des
excès de langage que je ne peux pas
accepter
je ne peux pas accepter d'entendre
certains de nos collègues faire une
comment dire une assimilation des black
blocks avec des militants qui dit avec
des militants qui défilent dans la rue
pour défendre la plupart du temps leurs
droits faisons attention aux propos que
l'on tient ce soir dans cet hémicycle
cet amalgame est honteux monsieur grands
je ne suis pas une black blocks je suis
une républicaine et je manifeste avec
d'autres pour défendre mes droits et la
citoyenne que je suis si relisez vous
relire et le compte rendu et la
citoyenne que je suis 20 noms veut que
ses doigts droits soient respectés et
nous considérons oui nous considérons
que les drones c'est bien joli pour
faire des films des beaux documentaires
vue du ciel mais que nous n'acceptons
pas qu'ils soient mises en place pour
surveiller nos libertés pour porter
atteinte à nos libertés parce que comme
pas comme pascal savoldelli le disais il
y a des gens qui manifestent
pacifiquement mais qui n'ont pas envie
d'être surveillé ce que vous proposez
l'art est totalement contre productif et
va justement créer les conditions pour
qu'à terme peut-être plus personne dans
notre pays faisons attention nous sommes
le temps que nous sommes
mais les temps peuvent changer et croyez
bien que nous essayons de contribuer à
ce qu'ils ne changent pas
pour aller d'un régime que ni vous ni
nous ne souhaitons faisant attention ce
qui n'a cessé contraire que j monsieur
grand essayer de réfléchir un petit peu
non non non mais essayez de réfléchir un
petit peu monsieur grand ce soir
donc je dis attention il y a des choses
que l'on croit juste mais qui à terme
s'avèrent dangereuses
merci même préville merci monsieur le
président monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
donc moi je vais en appui avec ce qui
vient d'être dit et comme il y en a ça
si en simple citoyenne qui qui va de
temps en temps à des manifestations et
je vais parler de la dernière grande
manifestation auquel ggg participer qui
était le 1er mai 2010 9 à paris et lors
de cette manifestation qui était une
manifestation pacifique bon enfant où on
avait défilé pendant quelques heures
déjà avec les personnes âgées des
enfants des poussettes et cetera
et quand on a vu au loin des gaz
lacrymogènes et on a senti qu'il se
passait quelque chose de loin tout le
monde a voulu refluer et sortir de la
manifestation ça n'a pas été possible
nous étions menacés et moi j'ai voulu
sortir avec ma fille et une amie et
c'était à chaque rue adjacente des crs
casque etc
alors bien sûr j'ai sorti ma carte de
sénatrice parce que moi j'avais peur et
je voulais partir donc on va laisser
sortir avec quelques personnes mais est
ce que c'est normal et tous les autres
qui étaient dans la manifestation et qui
avait peur d'être bousculé parce que ça
reflue est vide
évidemment ce que tout le monde avait
peur et tout le monde avec une envie
c'était de sortir on a quand même le
droit de manifester dans ce pays
et moi je vous le dis en tant que
citoyenne je n'ai pas du tout envie
d'être filmés et moi s'il ya un drone
qui passe au dessus avec un haut-parleur
qui me dit que l'on est filmée alors là
je me dis on est dans un autre monde
on doit pouvoir manifester et je vais
dire une dernière chose pour ce qui
concerne les black blocs se sont très
peu de personnes je pense qu'on sait les
identifier et que
et tout à fait le moyen de régler ce
problème sans empêcher la grande
majorité et comme c'est une tradition
dans notre pays de pouvoir manifester
voilà merci chers collègues donc je mets
aux voix les trois amendements
identiques 83 100es 296 avec un 12 avis
défavorable de la commission du
gouvernement entier pour qui et contre
qui s'abstient ils ne sont pas adoptées
passons à l'amendement 348 monsieur le
ministre il est défendu il vise
simplement à remettre mais je crois que
nous aurons une différence avec vous se
rapporteraient et la commission un
certain nombre de modifications telles
que l'arctique 22 étaient rédigées
venant de l'assemblée nationale
notamment la plus notable c'est le fait
de ne pas tomber dans un régime
d'autorisation préalable lorsque nous
faisons intervenir en période
administrative des drones
on pense que ça a compris il suffirait
beaucoup l'utilisation de ces drones
chevilly autant plus qu on a beaucoup
parlé d'ordre public mais évidemment le
drone sert à bien d'autres choses dans
le trafic de stupéfiants
chacun sait que lorsque la police
intervient lorsque les caméras sont
cisaillés jérôme bascher lézard évoqué
détruites ou simplement lorsque on ne
peut pas les installer parement que de
possibilité de passer la fibre ou de y
mettre en hauteur à cette ombre de
caméras s'ils sont bien utiles pour
lutter contre cette insécurité galopante
qui ressemble et trafic de stupéfiants
si à chaque fois que la police
gendarmerie utilise les drones pour
pouvoir intervenir il faut une
autorisation préfectorale vous comprenez
bien que ça va comme très largement
alourdir le travail de la police en tant
que surveillant son que c'est pas des
accords de fond et que la commission
mais évidemment un désaccord de femmes
qui est important parce qu il alourdit
la tâche administrative et atteint
judiciaire merci
rapporteur oui merci monsieur le
président que je viens d'évoquer
c'est cet amendement présenté par le
gouvernement est évidemment il note une
différence d'approché à septfonds assez
importante entre le gouvernement et nous
à l'instant où nous nous parlons alors
la première des choses que je voudrais
vous dire c'est que il s'est passé des
choses depuis que le texte a été voté
l'assemblée nationale il s'est passé une
chose c'est qu'il faudra noël buffet ici
présents avec l'accord du président du
sénat s'est souhaité saisir la cnil pour
avis que cet avis nous a été a été
délibérée par la commission nationale
informatique et libertés que la
présidente marie laure denis est venu
nous la présenter dans une audition
auquel un certain nombre de sénateurs
membres de la commission des lois ont pu
ont pu participer
c'est un atout un avantage considérable
du bicamérisme à la française et de la
voie 1 évidemment une évolution majeure
de loi de 2018 qui permet désormais à un
président de commission permanente tendu
d'une des deux assemblées de saisir la
une auto une autorité administrative
indépendante telle que la cnil pour
rendre un avis sur un texte de loi et ça
c'est très important si nous adoptions
cet amendement du gouvernement
donc forcément je suis défavorable nous
nous tirions un trait sur l'ensemble des
nouvelles garanties que nous proposons
elles sont deux
elles sont très très variés elle propose
de recentrer nouveau régime juridique
sur les seuls drones se garder des
appareils qui n'ont pas de pilote pour
bien le distinguer de régime plus souple
régissant les deux dispositifs que nous
verrons plus tard qui est celui des
caméras embarquées typiquement qu'équipe
les hélicoptères nous voulons mieux
encadrer les finalités justifiant
l'usagé de drones en réservant leur
usage à certaines circonstances où ils
sont particulièrement adaptés
les infractions graves les lieux
difficiles d'accès ou exposant les
agents à des dangers particuliers et on
veut prévoir régime souple
d'autorisation par le préfet ou par le
procureur selon les cas lorsque les
drones sont utilisés dans le cadre
d'opérations de police administrative ou
judiciaire
ça c'est important parce que pour ceux
qui ont été maires comme je l'étais et
ayant déployé 30 et une caméra dans ma
commune en haute savoie
on sait que
et quand vous a été évoquée par le
ministre richard tout à l'heure
l'encadrement de la cnil est extrêmement
dur très très bordés et le regard porté
par le représentant de l'état dans le
département
il est tout autant en amont dans l'aide
aux dans l'accompagnement de maître d
ouvrage avec le conseil de la police ou
de la gendarmerie mais aussi dans
l'arrêté préfectoral lui même qui est
circonstancié et puis on voulait on a
noté notamment des interdictions express
qui ferait que si léger sait si un jour
l'état voulait revenir sur ces
interdictions
il aurait évidemment repasser par le
parlement ce sont ces interdictions la
reconnaissance sociale des autres
collections tomassi a automatisé de
données et le son donc avis défavorable
monsieur le président merci monsieur le
rapporteur donc je mets aux voix cet
amendement 348 pendant de se mouiller
oui mais c'est présente merci monsieur
rapportant juste une précision j'entends
tous les arguments que vous évoquez que
je comprends qu'ils sont quelque part
une forme de gérer de contrôle ou en
tout cas de vision sur les procédures
mais j'entends aussi l'argument de
monsieur ministre sur la seule la
procédure de simplification
voilà donc tout le débat c'est des
pointes de l' équilibre entre le fait de
pouvoir justifier en même temps les
faits des opérationnels
donc voilà donc j'avoue que dans 7 des
proches là j'ai le sentiment que si on
veut respecter le droit on doit enfin le
droit actuel est en même temps cette
vision là on peut vous entendre mais
j'ai le sentiment que la peau seraient
extrêmement lourdes donc comment
garantir finalement que ont une capacité
de réactivité
malgré
finalement l'ensemble des questions qui
sont posées voilà c'était là ma question
bon j'avoue une précision de ce
rapporteur ses rapporteurs un de ses
ministres
moi j'en connais qui me yves honnêtement
on a on doit apporter des garanties en
face de chaque moment on risque
d'atteindre une liberté publique le sait
le sens de l'amendement de la commission
des lois la rigueur dans le président
buffet a parlé d abord c'est ça après on
peut toujours débattre
moi je considère qu'un préfet en matière
de police à vitrac livre ou un procureur
en matière de police judiciaire a
intérêt à avoir ne serait-ce que
connaissance connaissance des matériels
dont les forces dispose ça c'est quand
même intéressant de savoir que dans un
département où la rose en redressement
judiciaire de savoir quels sont les
matériels surtout dans les drones
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que j'ai à ma
disposition pour les opérations de
police voilà donc du coup bon j'entends
les choses et ça permettra d'avoir
notamment cnp le débat avec nos
collègues députés ministres alors dans
la pratique comment cela risque de se
passer c'est qu'on risque d'avoir des
soit une absence d'intervention parce
que il faudra faire effectivement un
syndrome de démarches administratives
sont l'accordera en amont comme
aujourd'hui procureur de la république y
en a ils accordent d'acquisitions dans
les caves ou dans les halls d'immeubles
et d'autres qui le font pas ils sont
plus aussi eu donc au risque comme
d'avoir une distorsion quand même
intervention ne s'inscrit dans le
domaine judiciaire ça va être aussi le
cas dans le domaine administratif m
s'immisce à l'intérieur peut donner des
consignes peut-être plus générale je
serais quand même dire qu'à ma
connaissance ne sera porteur après avoir
lu l'avis du tactile je n'y ai pas vu ce
que vous y avez vu mais c'est pour ça je
me vengerai nous interroger je n'ai pas
eu la ville active que l'acte il
autoriser j assure du drone que s'il y
avait une autorisation je n'ai pas lu
comme ça et est en tout cas ne rendez
pas obligatoire puis troisièmement je
laisse évidemment le parlement légiférer
comme il l'entend et ont été débuté
j'étais très jaloux également de mon
pouvoir parlementaire mais ce n'est pas
parce qu'une autorité administrative
donne un avis me semble-t-il qu'elle
engage législateur ou alors me semble je
crois que l'on risque effectivement
d'être dans une contrainte d'autorités
administratives qui empêchent quand même
l'action alors j'entends que les avis
sont éclairés ils sont positifs et il
nous aide tous avancé qu'il ya des
moments où on peut peut-être un peu
provoquer le destin moi je réponds à
l'intervention de monsieur le sénateur
je crois que ces drones seront très
efficace comme ils sont dans tous les
pays européens qui l'ont tour regardez
ce qui se passe en espagne regarder ce
qui se passe en italie ont regardé ce
qui se passe alors désormais en grande
bretagne ont regardé ce qui se passe en
belgique
l'utilisation des drones et généralisée
depuis bien longtemps aujourd'hui le
1500e ne fait plus volées de drones
parce que la cnil nous a demandé un
statut législatif ce que nous faisons
aujourd'hui
en attendant on peut pas les faire voler
à l'exception d'actes terroristes si
jamais il devait se dérouler encore
n'est pas tout à fait certain que ce
soit consacré pas par la législation
alors que partout autour de nous on fait
voler des drones pour lutter contre les
trafics de stupéfiants pour lutter
contre un certain nombre de difficultés
de violences urbaines par exemple voilà
ebi j'oserais dire quand même que dans
l'amendement puisque je te présenter
assez vite monsieur le président nous
avions également mis que dans les
hélicoptères et dans les ballons captifs
on avait le pouvoir des images ça
existait auparavant la commission des
lois du sénat l'a refusée
on s'en étonner parce que nous pensons
qu'un hélicoptère ou un ballon captif
peut également permettre de faire des
prises images qui permettent justement
intervention hier soir dans la ville de
blois par exemple heureusement qu'il ya
eu des hélicoptères pour pouvoir
permettre de remettre l'ordre public
dans un quartier est quand même fallu
envoyer quelques centaines de gendarmes
parce qu'on n'avait pas forcément les
yeux pour le voir sans doute été plus
économes en force et plus efficace dans
l'ordre public si on avait pu avoir une
image retransmis comme cela existe dans
les feux de forêt dans cette forêt c'est
exactement ce qui se passe on utilise
des drones
on utilise des hélicoptères pour pouvoir
regarder ce qui se passe et pour faire
les moyens d'intervention des pompiers
il n'y a aucune raison que tout le monde
ait possibilité alors de drones en
france sauf la police ou dans des
conditions extrêmement compliqué donc je
maintiens évidemment l'amendement
monsieur va cher monsieur le président
et le ministre collègues
nous sommes évidemment dans une ligne de
crête car tous ici nous savons que nous
avons besoin d'une meilleure efficacité
de la police et des forces de
gendarmerie
faux le valtin de l'ordre mais c'est
vrai que nous savons aussi la chambre je
me disais depuis hélas pas pendant
plusieurs années le gouvernement a
appris quelques mesures de restriction
des libertés publiques on l'a vu avec le
colisée c'est pour ça que nous sommes
jaloux ici au sénat de bien avoir un
régime rpt ou le gouvernement prend
rendez vous régulièrement avec nous pour
savoir s'il peut confiner le pays et
donc sur toutes ces mesures de libertés
publiques contrôler nos réticences car
il ya une vraie offensive de ce point de
vue là mais il ya aussi et vous avez
raison
une offensive des forces de plus en plus
compliqué pour détruire la démocratie
qu'on la dit très bientôt leur monde ami
le sénateur de l'hérault
c'est assez important de penser à cela
qu'il ya une vraie limite à trouver je
pense que la cmp doit la trouver
mais je vais terminer mon propos par un
point
la france a raté les drones militaires
ne voulant pas qui
pilote au moment où il faut regarder où
il faut armer nous avons été en retard
dieu d'un combat d'une bataille comme en
je ne voudrais pas que nous rations
aussi les drones civils de la protection
civile de la protection de nos
concitoyens
merci chers collègues donc écoutez je
vais mettre aux voix cet amendement 348
du gouvernement avec un avis défavorable
de la commission qui et pour qui et
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté l'ordre du jour appelle la suite
de la discussion de la proposition de
loi adoptée par l'assemblée nationale
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée relatives à la sécurité
globale dont la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 3 147 au sein de l'article 22
nous avons donc six amendements et un
sous-amendement qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 347 est présenté
par le gouvernement monsieur le ministre
un président il s'agit de permettre aux
polices municipales d'utiliser les
drones qui nous avons beaucoup occupé
hier pour des motifs évidemment qui
relève de la police du maire notamment
la salubrité publique par exemple le
fait de regarder la gestion ça a été dit
hier par quelques sénateurs du groupe
heller des déchets sur la voie publique
par exemple donc il s'agit effectivement
de filer la métaphore drones de
l'article 22 ministres monsieur le
président vous présenter le
sous-amendement même le président nomme
la présidence je ministre chers
collègues ce sous-amendement 388 a pour
objectif en réalité de permettre
l'expérimentation de l'usagé de ces
systèmes par les polices municipales je
crois que ils paraissent importants
qu'elles puissent avoir recours à ce
moyen
il n'empêche qu'il est nécessaire sans
doute qu'il y ait cette petite période
d'expérimentation avant qu ensuite les
choses soient parfaitement cadré pour
qu'ensuite des choses soient
parfaitement cadré
à la fois sur le plan de l'usaj de la
capacité de la formation est bien
évidemment de la réglementation voilà
l'objet de cet amendement merci nous
allons examiner maintenant le 131
rectifié monsieur benarroch monsieur
gontard pardon oui merci madame merci
madame la présidente
on a vu hier soir que cet article 22
pause éprouvé des problèmes
bon les amendements de retrait n'ont pas
été n'ont pas été voter mais on voit
bien que la commission s'est posé des
questions et à essayer d'encadrer
l'usagé usage des drones est donc cet
amendement qui est inspiré des travaux
de notre collègue député pour la forte à
rennes justement pour objet de préciser
et de renforcer la rédaction d'actuels à
li na 6 pour garantir que qu'en aucune
façon des images de drones filmant
l'intérieur des domiciles puisse être
visionnées comme le prévoit actuellement
le texte il complète le dispositif en
ajoutant les espaces extérieurs privés
et l'intérieur des véhicules le respect
de la vie privée l'intimité des
personnes doit être le même que l'on
soit allongé sur son canapé affairés
dans son jardin au volant de sa voiture
en contrepartie d'extension du champ du
dispositif
il en exclut les opérations de sécurité
civile et je pense tout particulièrement
aux opérations à 110 et donc je
m'interroge au passage sur l'actuelle
rédaction daniel si ce qui exclut
l'utilisation des images de domicile
pour l'utilisation justement des
opérations de sécurité civile or s'il
est justement un cas de figure aux
fumées ou en tout cas utiliser les
images à le filmer à l'intérieur d'un
domicile avec un drone peut se justifier
c'est bien pour une opération sauvetage
lors d'un incendie
c'est donc un amendement cohérent avec
la philosophie qui a voulu être donné
par la commission sur l'actuel article
il exclut donc toute visualisation
d'image à caractère privé par les
services de police et limite leur usage
à la seule et à la stricte protection
civile des personnes merci merci
l'amendement 329 actifs
monsieur richard la brillance et un
amendement qui suit simplement à
corriger une référence de textes de
manière à éviter toute ambiguïté sur
l'espace sera plus de même le champ
visuel sur lequel les caméras aéroportée
peut intervenir et ça rejoint donc la
préoccupation de préoccupation de
protection de la vie privée ou des
domiciles merci la maman 208 rectifié
bis madame gatel si madame la présidente
je serais bref je considère qu'il est
défendu parce que c'est un moment
reprend largement les observations de
notre collègue richard je remercie très
bien la maman de 306 monsieur ravier
merci maintenant la présidente madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues il est primordial de
garantir le respect de la protection de
la vie privée dans le cadre de
l'exploitation des images prises par
drones lors de manifestations cette
proposition de loi doit garantir une
meilleure protection des forces de
l'ordre et une plus grande efficacité de
leurs actions sans tomber dans la
tentation big brother ses excès en
travers et l'urgente et légitime
nécessité de remettre notre pays en
ordre
il convient donc de refuser la
reconnaissance faciale par les drones ou
l'intrusion dans la vie privée des
domiciles et de l'écrire clairement dans
cet article
cependant pas mon amendement je souhaite
rétablir la capacité pour les forces de
l'ordre de pouvoir filmer les parties
communes des immeubles qui sont des
parties non privatives ainsi que dans
celle des entrepôts il n'aura échappé à
personne que les halls d'immeubles sont
souvent le lieu de nombreux trafics en
particulier des trafics de drogue et en
particulier dans de nombreux sites et
marseillaise des trafics à l'abri du
regard des forces de l'ordre est
toujours au détriment des habitants de
ces immeubles concernés qui finissent
par être pris en otage dans leur propre
d'homicide il est également de notoriété
publique que le mode de fonctionnement
des black blocs ou autres mouvements
d'extrême gauche s'appuie en amont et en
aval de leur action contre les commerces
et mobilier urbain où les forces de
l'ordre sur l'utilisation des parties
communes des immeubles ou d'entrepôts à
proximité des zones demain
facilitation ou sur leur trajet pour
connaître leurs exactions
en effet ce qu'on appelle les halls
d'immeuble certains échapper aux
fouilles et des forces de l'ordre aux
points d'entrée des manifestations il
caché du matériel qui deviendront
ensuite des armes par destination
mais ils servent également de refuge
lorsque les forces de l'ordre tentent le
procédé à leur interpellation
il paraît donc proportionnée et pour le
bien de tous
sans entraves à la vie et à la propriété
privée de permettre aux drones de capter
des images dans les parties communes
d'immeubles d'habitation ou d'entrepôts
et dans le respect strict des
dispositions de cet article merci
l'amendement 318 ray rectifiée bien ce
monsieur richard le caractère d'un
reliquat en effet j'avais déposé devant
la commission il ya déjà quelques jours
un amendement qui permettait
l'utilisation de drones sur certaines
finalité comme l'a dit le ministre tout
à l'heure par les polices municipales
parlée par les municipalités
malheureusement victime de mon
inexpérience et aussi de l'imagination
inépuisable de nos amis de la commission
des finances
je me suis heurté à l'application de
l'article 40 contre cet amendement tout
en réfléchissant quand même une pesos en
disant qu' une un drone coûte souvent
moins cher qu'une seule caméra installée
en fixe donc j'avais dû y renoncer et je
suis d'autant plus reconnaissants aux
ministres et à la commission d'avoir
utilisé ce point de départ pour faire
l'amendement 347 qui répond parfaitement
à mon objectif initial et à la
commission de l'avoir complété avec
notamment caractère expérimental
justifier que vient défendre le
président buffet donc lorsque le 3 en 47
sera approuvé comme je l'espère
naturellement je devrais retirer 318 et
remercie monsieur richard ne connaissant
votre persévérance monsieur le ministre
quel est votre avis sur le
sous-amendement 388 rapportera pardon
mais comme je faisais appeler sur le
moment l'amendement allez-y
sur le sous-amendement le président
buffet monsieur richard viennent le dire
nous avons fait un travail en commun
j'aurais excusant problème notre
collègue louis gay harvey qui a un
travail remarquable vous savez sur tous
ces sujets et qui malheureusement est
empêché pour une raison d'urgence
médicale donc je prends le relais mais
nous avons travaillé ensemble le
sous-amendement évidemment du président
buffet nous permet d'aller vers
l'expérimentation avec toutes les
garanties
donc évidemment que la commission y est
favorable et que une fois sous-amendé
elle sera favorable à l'amendement du
gouvernement présenté à ma demande si le
rapporteur pardon non non c'est moi qui
vous sur les autres amendements le 318
c'est une demande de rapport le sénat y
est traditionnellement opposés sur alors
sur les drones dans les lieux privés
madame gatel et il ya un amendement 131
qui parle des espaces privés et 1 208
qui parle des lieux privés l'exclusion
des espaces privés ou des lieux privés
me semble trop large
on peut imaginer que les opérations de
police aient besoin d' images captées
depuis la voie publique dans des espaces
qui eux ne sont pas ouverts au public
par exemple des partys privés des
entrepôts mais tel que c'est rédigé
c'est beaucoup trop large
on a eu le débat hier soir donc je
souhaiterais que vous retiriez cet
amendement sachant qu'en définitive la
position de loïc hervé de notre apport à
porter de doctrine d'emploi qui quelque
part va aborder tous a expliqué dans
quelles conditions savas leur réponds à
votre sollicitation de jeu préféré que
vous leur thiriez même chose sur le 131e
chez richard j'aurais dit sagesse sur
son amendement mais compte tenu de ce
qu'on vient de dire je pense que le
problème réglé et monsieur ravier qui
autorise la captation du mode des images
dans les halls d'immeubles pour parfaire
le débat nous sommes défavorables très
bien monsieur l'omi
trait aux avis sur les différents
amendements du président la commission
des lois évident qu'un avis favorable
pour l'expérimentation bien sûr dire au
ministre richard effectivement que il
est là la paternité de l'amendement
gouvernemental
à la suite de l'évocation du débat
devant les commissions des finances et
donc ainsi un avis défavorable sur son
moment le rapport par définition puisque
il a fait d'être le débat qu'il
souhaitait et puis peut-être pour madame
gatel et les autres maux qui veulent
réduire les possibilités des captations
comme l'a évoqué monsieur le ministre de
bresse j'entends là le souci légitime
cependant je dois dire deux choses
d'abord les drones
ils peuvent être utilisés chacun le
comprend dans des cas où on a besoin de
connaître un certain nombre de lieux
privés
je pense par exemple de prise d'otages
il est évident que la prise d'otages se
fait rarement sur la voie publique et
ensuite on va dans un endroit qui est un
endroit dit privé et ce serait quand
même un peu étonnant qu'on ne puisse pas
utiliser nos en seriez d'accord ces
possibilités d'image
deuxièmement ce que nous faisons sur
tours avec l'utilisation de ces drones
c'est éviter la surexposition des
personnels les personnels évidemment la
gendarmerie et de la police nationale
sont le fait par l'intermédiaire de
caméras embarquées comme vous les voyez
ça parfois dans les documentaires sont
le fais pas ta manière de chiens qui
sont parfois équipés soit on le fait par
intermédiaire de drones c'est évidemment
une contrepartie si j'ose dire
d'utilisation et technologique puis
troisièmement dans la sécurité civile on
utilise également ses drones et ils vont
dans des lieux privés ou des parties
privées ne serait ce que pour pouvoir
aider les services de pompiers ou de
secours d'intervenir donc je ne pense
pas que restreindre le champ en disant
que ce ne peut être que sur la voie
publique serait très utile ensuite comme
technologie en revanche j'entends le
souci des parlementaires jouer comme ça
remarquer que le texte
et je voudrais également saluer monsieur
le rapporteur m
et prévoit des garanties d'avoir des
garanties d'information l'article 22 le
prévoir extrêmement clairement de la
part des gens qui sont effectivement
possible possiblement touchés ne prévoit
pas le fait de filmer des intérieurs de
domicile c'est un point très important
la différence entre le privé et le
domicile les domiciles ainsi que les
parties communes et les entrées lorsque
les opérations on a vu hier que le
parlement souhaitait un régime de
déclaration d'autorisation de la part du
préfet ou du procureur de la république
selon les finalités sens que si la
finalité c'est la voie publique
alors il est très clairement écrit dans
la loi qu'on ne peut pas filmer les
parties communes à l'intérieur de cette
utilisation de technologies
donc je crois qu'il faut avoir le bon
équilibre il me semble que le texte
pratique 22la entre la nécessaire
utilisation notamment et prise d'otage
des drones à l'intérieur de domaine
privé et en même temps l'interdiction de
filmer des domiciles et de garantir
évidemment le renseignement des
personnes qui seraient concernées donc
un avis défavorable même si je comprends
la philosophie des divers un moment très
bien merci monsieur le ministre avant de
passer au vote je voudrais et donner la
parole à mai seront tard je voudrais
quand même adressé tous nos voeux de
prompt rétablissement aux rapporteurs
loïc hervé monsieur gontard vous avez
demandé un oui merci madame la
présidente je m'associe aux voeux de
rétablissement et loïc hervé bien sûr
plus questionné le rapporteur sur sur
donc l'amendement 131 parce que le
rapporteur nous dit que c'est un
problème de précisions alors qu'il me
semble qu'au contraire c'est un
amendement qui vient préciser justement
le travail qui a été fait qui a été fait
en commission puisque il définit
justement clairement les lieux qui ne
seront pas qu'ils ne doivent pas être
trop filmé domicile entre et espace exr
de propriété privée intérieure des
véhicules dont il semble qu'il va plutôt
dans le sens de la commission pour
clairement définir les lieux qu'ils ne
peuvent pas l'être
et puis surtout également il vient
encadrer comme l'a dit le ministre
l'utilisation
en termes de sécurité civile notamment
en termes en cas d' incendies et donc je
pense qu'il va plutôt dans le sens je
comprends pas bien du coup la réponse
qui a été faite sur cet amendement
puisque c'est un petit peu pour le cool
inverse et qui vient plutôt sécuriser
l'utilisation des images des drones
merci je fais une rectification ce n'est
pas loïc hervé mais c'est la maman de
loïc hervé françoise gatel et merci
madame la présidente je pense que notre
collègue sera touchée de la sympathie
qu'on l'exprimé qui touche effectivement
ça sa maman je vais retirer l'amendement
déposé par le président marseille je
pense que j'arriverai à le convaincre de
la sagesse et de la pertinence et du
rapporteur et tu ministre il comprendra
et j'en profite si vous le permettez
pour faire une explication de vote sur
les deux amendements 347 et 388 madame
la présidente
moi je suis favorable à ces amendements
avec l'expérimentation qui est sagement
proposé parce que je pense que cela doit
rassurer tous les collègues qui traîne
et qui ont peur et expérimenté est
souvent un signe de sagesse
ce que cela permet à la fois de capter
la confiance de chacun mais aussi
d'ajuster les éléments qui sont
nécessaires et ceux ci un acte de
confiance envers la police municipale et
surtout un acte d'efficacité en matière
de sécurité donc je pense à un moment de
protection des libertés
je vous remercie madame après monsieur
présidence à vie a demandé la parole non
par fait très bien donc je vais procéder
au vote du sous-amendement 388 avec deux
avis favorables qui votent pour contre
qui s'abstient il est adopté le vote de
l'amendement ainsi sous-amendé 347 qui
votent pour contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté le 131 tombe le 3 129 tombes le
208 et retiré l'amendement 306 est
l'objet de deux avis défavorables
il est non c'est monsieur ravier il
n'est pas retirée monsieur richard
monsieur ravier nous votons votre
amendement qui votent pour qu'ils votent
contre
il n'est pas adoptée et le 318 est
retiré nous passons à l'amendement 218e
présenter ma part madame qu kirmann oui
merci à madame la présidente monsieur
ministre comme nous l'avions dit dans la
discussion générale nous saluons le
travail notamment de la commission des
lois pour mieux encadrer l'usagé des
drones ou souhaitons cependant frères
cet amendement qui puisse être précisé
dans cet article 22 que ceux ci ne
peuvent pas être utilisés dans le cadre
de l'identification des personnes
filmées
monsieur le ministre vous monsieur le
rapporteur part dans votre avis
non c'est une interdiction de
l'identification de personnes pardon on
était contraire à l'objet même de ce
qu'on vient de voter donc par définition
défavorable défavorable je mets aux
voileux 218 avec deux avis défavorables
qui votent pour contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas adopté le 2 119 adam kreek
herman où il s'agit bardon merci à
madame la présidente monsieur miss mes
chers collègues il s'agit à travers cet
amendement de préciser qu'il soit
prohibé l'installation de dispositifs
d'armement porter c'est ce qu'on a
appelé la non demande star wars cela je
pense qu'on est complètement
dehors du sujet et que pardon c'est ce
qu'on a appelé l'amendement star wars je
pense qu'on est complètement en dehors
du sujet que ce sont des procès
d'intention qui sont absolument pas
pertinent défavorable monsieur le
ministre mais ma ville je mets aux
voileux 219 avec deux avis défavorables
qui votent pour contre il a déjà été
rejetée on a une certaine cadence
donc cet amendement n'est pas adoptée
nous en sommes aux l'amendement 373
présenté par le rapporteur
alors c'est l'amant auquel je faisais
allusion tout à l'heure en réponse à
madame gatel qui avait le fait l'objet
de beaucoup de travail de notre collègue
l'eau et hervé qu'on peut appeler une
véritable doctrine d'emploi des drones
donc évidemment il est rédigé en 6
alinéa les lits sont des lignes
directrices qui permettent de préciser
les garantes les exigences de formation
des personnels les garanties juridiques
générales énoncées par la loi les cas
concrets ou d'usagé drone peut être
considérée comme proportionnée au regard
des finalités de la loi c'est très
important pour éviter les risques
constitutionnels et surtout définir les
spécificités si fication technique qui
si elles n'ont pas leur place dans la
loi sont indispensables pour s'assurer
que les dispositifs sont potentiellement
ne portent pas d'une atteinte
disproportionnée à la vie privée ce qui
répond aux amendements précédent donc je
pense qu'avec ce travail sur riddick
important nous avons toutes les
garanties nécessaires pour pouvoir
mettre en place expérimentation merci
monsieur le rapporteur monsieur le
ministre votre avis sagesse je mets donc
aux voiles la maintenance 373 madame
petermann demande la parole
merci pour l'explication merci à madame
la présidente monsieur le ministre
bien évidemment cet amendement
certainement moins loin que ce que nous
avions déposé précédemment mais il
démontre en tout cas s'il en était
besoin qu'il ya quand même de nombreuses
inquiétudes qu'il y a besoin de
sécuriser en tout cas ce dispositif et
que donc finalement star wars ne semble
pas être si loin et que tout le monde
semble vouloir s'en prémunir et donc
nous voterons cet amendement un avis
donc favorable de la commission un avis
de sagesse du gouvernement qui votent
pour
si votre contre qui s'abstient il est
donc adopté le numéro 240 madame clic
herrmann il est défendu va dans le même
sens que les précédents thor votre avis
est favorable jamais donc au bout avec
deux avis défavorables qui votent pour
contre il n'est pas adopté le 132 me
gontard
oui merci madame madame la présidente
cet amendement vient également sécurisé
et puis je dirais faire en sorte que ce
projet de loi
effectivement sécuriser ce pseudo ce
projet de loi le 22 décembre dernier le
conseil d'état vous a infligé ainsi
qu'au préfet de police de paris un
véritable camouflet en interdisant
d'utiliser les drones dessous pour
surveiller les rassemblements sur la
voie publique
dans sa décision le conseil d'état
dénoncée même le dispositif dans son
essence
le ministe n'apporte pas d'éléments de
nature à établir que l'objectif de
garantie de la sécurité publique lors de
rassemblements de personnes soit un
public ne pourrait être atteint
pleinement dans les circonstances
actuelles
en l'absence de recours à des drones
endroits des données personnelles si
l'utilité d'un dispositif de
surveillance n'est pas clairement
démontré il ne peut jamais être autorisé
en matière de données sensibles telles
que les opinions politiques capteurs
méditation il faut même que le
dispositif soit absolument nécessaire au
maintien de l'ordre
cette proposition de loi ne justifie en
rien cette absolue nécessité et donc
rien ne vient justifier cette atteinte
grâce est gravissime droit de manifester
et à la liberté d'opinion on en a déjà
parlé hier soir
merci merci monsieur le rapporteur votre
avis sur le mouvement 132
alors comme j'aime le dire la commission
a présenté une doctrine d'emploi des
drones et à la spécifiquement cadre l
usage de ces drones lors des
rassemblements publics en exigeant des
circonstances particulières soient
réunies lorsqu'il y a des craintes de
troubles à l'ordre public d'une
particulière gravité
lorsque les circonstances liées au lieu
de l'opération rendent difficile le
recours à d'autres outils de captation
d'image ou lorsque ces circonstances
sont susceptibles d'exposer leurs agents
à le danger significatif avec cet
encadrement
nous pensons avoir bien cadrer le
problème est donc défavorable
merci monsieur le ministre mama vit très
bien
je mets donc aux voileux 132 avec deux
avis défavorables qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté l'amendement 133 monsieur
gontard oui merci madame la présidente
cet amendement et intervient sur
l'utilisation des drones pour la
surveillance des frontières
je m'étendrai pas sur la politique
migratoire de la france aussi inhumaine
qu'inefficace mais je vais tenter de
vous convaincre avec des arguments
rationnels
le retour d'expérience de la
surveillance de la frontière
américano-mexicaine par un drone fêtede
état d' une immense gabegie financière
cette politique est coûteuse et
inefficace en 2015
un rapport de la sécurité intérieure cet
état de 1 1% d'arrestation de
clandestins permise par les drones pour
un budget global de 62 5 millions
d'euros
clairement l'intervention humaine et
moins onéreuse et plus efficace pire
encore on apprenait en 2016 que les
cartels mexicains pirates et les gps des
drones surveillant la frontière pour
l'affranchir tranquillement cette
inefficacité sans doute à l'origine de
la volonté de l'ex président en train de
construire son fameux mur il connaît ya
plus de succès et qui est une autre
gabegie s'agissant de l'europe les
chiffres montrent l'explosion du budget
de l'agencé frontex de 137 millions
d'euros en 2010 2015 à 322 millions
d'euros en 2020 selon ces les chiffres
de la cour des comptes européenne et une
automatisation toujours plus grande de
la surveillance des frontières et
parallèlement le ratio entre le nombre
de personnes qui tentent de franchir la
méditerranée et le nombre de
qu'ils y laissent la vie ne fait
qu'augmenter cette automatisation de la
surveillance aux frontières n'est donc
une nouvelle façon pour les autorités
européennes d'accentuer le drame et qui
continue de se jouer en méditerranée
pour une efficacité qui finalement ne
profite qu'aux industries de la
surveillance à l'échelle de la france la
problématique est la même ces drames
humains interviennent chaque jour dans
les alpes
en plus d'être littéralement inhumaines
la surveillance de la frontière par
drones nous semble particulièrement
onéreuse et inopportune donc il faut
bien sûr encadré et interdire
l'utilisation des drones pour la
surveillance des frontières
merci merci monsieur le président
monsieur le rapporteur votre avis s'il
vous plaît monsieur le sénateur nous
pensons très exactement le contraire
franchement il faut pas aller à la
frontière américano mexicaine il suffit
d'aller à la frontière franco italienne
où il y à toute une série de régions
montagneuses pour voir que la
surveillance de grandes étendues de
nature par des drones permet au
contraire de percevoir s'il ya des
franchissements illégaux de la frontière
ça n'empêche pas d'avoir un traitement
humain humaniser de la manière dont on
peut faire des des interpellations
mais en tout cas pour la surveillance le
drone et tout est beaucoup moins onéreux
est tout à fait adapté donc avis
défavorable même avis monsieur le
ministre je mets donc au voilà
maintenant 133 mhz à damas à 6 par mois
merci madame la présidente j'ai bien
entendu à la fois la défense de
l'amendement de monsieur gontard et les
propos de monsieur le rapporteur
cela rapporterait vous dire le fond de
ma pensée en une phrase vous venez de
faire la démonstration de la société
dont on ne veut pas
mais c'est mon tard bon bah je n'aurais
pas grand chose à rajouter mais monsieur
le rapporteur nous explique justement la
configuration de la faune que la
frontière italienne et et le fait que
les âges des drones serait est
indispensable je vous invite à y aller
réellement voir ce qui se passe à la
frontière italienne et notamment à
montgenèvre et effectivement les cas
devait clairement d'inhumanité de
d'accidents qui peuvent se produire tous
les jours et l'utilisation de drones
dans les conditions de montagne je vous
invite vraiment y aller vous verrez ce
que c'est et ça ne fonctionne pas on à
doubler voire tripler les effectifs ça
ne fonctionne pas donc moi je pense que
ici on pourrait un petit peu être
pragmatique sur les politiques qu'on met
en place ouvrir les yeux regarder et
voir que ça ne fonctionne pas et que
d'autres politiques serait peut-être
utile
franchement aller voir aussi du côté
italien discuter avec les élus côté
italien ils vous diront exactement la
même chose donc je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faut ouvrir les choses agir et
mettre en place un accueil digne ou en
tout cas faire en sorte que la politique
qu'on veut mettre en place que vous
voulez mettre en place de la france se
fasse dans les règles des droits de
l'homme et de je dirais des droits tout
court parce que c'est pas ce qui se
passe actuellement à montgenèvre
si on voulait respecter les droits à
montgenèvre il faudrait faire un centre
d'accueil ce qui n'est absolument pas le
cas on refuse les demandes les
demandeurs d'asile on les revoit en
italie je pourrais parler de menton des
centres centre de jeu c'est pas comme on
les appelle d'enfermement puisqu'ils ne
sont pas ils ne sont pas définies je
rappelle qu'il ya eu à un arrêt récent
qui intime au préfet de permettre
justement aux parlementaires aux
associations d'aller dans ces lieux
puisqu'on y est allé à plusieurs
reprises et on nous y a refusé donc je
pense qu'il est temps que la france
respecte les droits
merci merci monsieur le ministre
souhaiter la parole oui merci à un prix
encore une fois je peux pas laisser dire
des choses ainsi dans l'hémicycle en
l'occurrence monsieur c'est d'abord un
pas anormal que la france comme tous les
pays veulent
préserver sa souveraineté et ses
frontières et c'est pas un mauvais mot
d'avoir des frontières et une
souveraineté et deuxièmement je voudrais
vous dire que les conditions dans
lesquelles les étrangers viennent sur le
sol national sont on ne peut plus digne
et conforme effectivement aux droits de
l'homme sur 142 mille demandes d'asile
la france est le pays en europe ont
forcément à sa population qui à
l'accueil de plus de demandeurs d'asile
en europe
148 une demande d'asile et lorsque l'on
voit les vous dit ce n'est pas assez
efficace
l'italie l'année dernière après constaté
34 mille demandeurs d'asile sur son sol
passant par l'italie et rien qu'à la
frontière italienne et une 38000 38
mille reconduites à la frontière je
crois qu'on peut dire que des policiers
les gendarmes et les agents de la
préfecture dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles parfois avec des
militants politiques et parfois ils
comprennent des parlementaires qui
viennent embêter pour ne pas dire plus
les gendarmes qui roulaient policiers
qatar et dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles je crois qu'effectivement de
pouillon souligné nous pourrions nous
pourrions souligné effectivement le
grand calme est la grande efficacité de
la police et de la gendarmerie de la
république et puis troisièmement je
voudrais souligner ici
nous avons par exemple dans l'exemple de
manteaux que vous évoquez d'abord les
italiens ils sont d'accord avec nous
c'est tellement vrai que sous deux
gouvernements différents
nous voulons mettre en place et ont reçu
la ministre italienne nos intérieurs
encore hier et ont eu trois s'échangent
en allant directement à rome et moi même
étant rendu plusieurs fois à menton à
bardonecchia ou à vintimille la première
fois un contrôle de patrouille en commun
franco italien dont contrairement à ce
que vous dites le gouvernement italien
et les italiens partage tout à fait
votre avis on va parler des élus mais je
pense que la plupart des élus que j'ai
rencontrés dans les alpes-maritimes
je pense qu'ils ne sont pas de votre
avis politique monsieur c'est le moins
complice qu'on puisse dire est deuxième
sujet on voit bien que l'une des
difficultés et vous n'en parlez jamais
c'est celle des passeurs ce qui fonde la
traite d'êtres humains et que attention
la façon dont aujourd'hui sont traités
un dignement les étrangers qui sont en
situation irrégulière premier centre au
sol
c'est pas l'état qui les protège c'est
les passes
des organisations criminelles des
organisations criminelles et c'est eux
que nous devons que nous devons
combattre
donc il est normal de protéger ses
frontières dans un état souverain sauf à
expliquer qu'il n'y a pas de problème
avec les frontières qui a pas de
problème avec la souveraineté et qu'on
doit laisser tout le monde aller
n'importe où il ya des règles pour venir
sur le territoire national nous
souhaitons les faire respecter comme
l'ensemble des pays européens en
parfaite collaboration avec l'italie et
que par ailleurs nous devons résoudre
des problèmes plus profonds qui sont ce
soit des dvd d ordre climatique soit des
désordres économiques soient des
désordres politiques
ce que la france fait très largement
puisque l add-on et l'octroi à peu près
trente mille demandes d'asile par an à
certaines à certaines nationalités qui
sont effectivement porsche est
pourchassé dans leur pays pour des
raisons d'ordre sexuel politique
évidemment
et là en plus t'as france indépendamment
de avoir comme conséquence la difficulté
de la frontière franco-italienne la
difficulté notre région puisque je
constate par ailleurs qu'une grande
partie de ces migrants souhaite aller
pour une migration de travail chez nos
amis britanniques
et donc c'est à la fois un pays d'entrée
est un pays d'accueil
c'est quand même pas particulièrement
remarquable avec le sang-froid me
semble-t-il du peuple français des
policiers des gendarmes qui l'ont
élections dans des conditions
extrêmement difficiles au père et je
crois qu'on ne peut pas laisser dire ce
que vous avez dit sur la prise de la
république qui le fait dans de grandes
conditions de dignité
en ce qui concerne l'arrêt du tribunal
administratif de nice
c'est un arrêt du tribunal initiative de
nice effectivement nous allons pouvoir
ouvrir tous les centres évidemment à
chacun je rappelle que juste à menton je
rappelle jusqu'à menton ce n'est pas un
centre de rétention
c'est que tous les quatre heures nous
remettons à la police italienne faut pas
dire n'importe quoi non plus monsieur le
sénateur dans l'hémicycle tous les
quatre heures nous remettons mais oui
mais oui parce qu'on ne peut pas laisser
dire n'importe quoi sur les services de
l'état c'est insultant pour les
policiers des gendarmes qui tous les
jours travaille dans des conditions de
grande humanité et dans des conditions
difficiles et tous les quatre heures
tous les quatre heures nous remettons à
la police italienne
effectivement ces migrants qui attendent
dans le site de menton donc quand vous
nous inviter à aller voir ce qui se
passe en effet je pense que vous pourrez
considérer que nous connaissons bien
nous avons juste un avis dit
du vôtre elle aime même masse a demandé
la parole merci madame la présidente
monsieur pardon monsieur président
canard pour un rappel au règlement
oui madame la présidente monsieur
ministre puis dire nous essayons d'avoir
un dialogue respectueux ici au sein de
l'hémicycle
ce n'est pas la première fois que vous
utilisez cette phrase à l'égard d'un
sénateur d'une sénatrice
vous dites n'importe quoi excusez moi
vous pouvez être défavorable à l'opinion
que nous émettons à l'égard d'une de vos
propositions mais un peu de respect avec
les sénateurs de la haute assemblée je
vous lis très simplement on peut se
parler avec des termes qui soient un peu
plus sympathique à notre égard je le dis
très simplement merci de prendre acte
madame la présidente
j'en prends acte même si ce n'est pas
vraiment un rappel au règlement
madame med massa
à l'endroit des réfugiés nous sommes des
parlementaires et c'est notre travail de
faire cela comme nous allons visiter
aussi des prisons des cra et nous allons
nous avons été un mouton plusieurs fois
nous allons à la frontière
franco-italienne écoutes et arrêtés
quand même de garder cette sorte de
suspicion sur les parlementaires qui
irait à l'encontre des lois
souvenez vous un peu de l'histoire vous
qui nous fait des longs cool d'histoire
depuis mardi qu' il y a eu dans le passé
aussi quelques parlementaires ils
n'étaient pas nombreux à aider ceux qui
fuyaient la guerre ceux qui fuyaient les
camps et qui connaît un pays d'accueil
soit disant et nous ne montrons pas
l'exemple et arrêtez de nous montrer du
doigt nous faisons notre travail et
laissez nous faire notre travail parce
que vous au niveau de l'accueil des
réfugiés et des migrants vous ne faites
pas grand chose votre politique mais
qu'un échec
voilà merci merci sa collègue monsieur
durand toi oui je vais commencer par
voir un mot de sympathie à l'égard de
notre collègue louis carré puisque nous
n'avions pas encore manifestés en lui
souhaitant le meilleur dans les heures
qui viennent
s'agissant de de la nature du débat et
des termes du débat que nous avons
j'ai le sentiment que que ministre à
quand un petit problème avec le
parlement donc nous disons n'importe
quoi c'était vrai pour moi hier c'était
vrai ce matin
je ne peux pas vous laisser dire ça les
parlementaires qui embête les forces de
l'ordre excusez nous excusez nous on est
quand même réussi attaché au bon
fonctionnement de nos institutions et
nous sommes les premiers sur le terrain
dans nos circonscriptions dans nos
communes à respecter à rendre hommage et
accompagner le travail des gendarmes et
des policiers donc le côté on a le
monopole de la sécurité commence à
devenir un petit peu fatigant par
ailleurs dans le rapport entre le
gouvernement et le parlement
qu'est ce qu'on observe depuis hier tous
les âmes les amendements de suppression
que vous avez déposé sur l'excellent
travail qui a fait la commission des
lois en matière de garanties apportées
sur un certain nombre de sujets qui le
justifiait parce que le défenseur des
droits ne dit pas n'importe quoi
la cncdh ne dit pas n'importe quoi la
cnil ne dit pas n'importe quoi et donc
quand nous sommes ici parlementaire en
train d'essayer d'améliorer le texte
nous faisons notre travail dans une
procédure simplifiée sur un texte bancal
une proposition de loi qui vise à être
un projet de loi passe tout ça ça finit
par faire beaucoup
donc ce texte qui est quand même bricolé
n'est pas le bon véhicule législatif
pour traiter de sujets aussi importants
on l'a dit à plusieurs reprises on fait
ça à la va vite on y reviendra sans
doute bientôt ça fait partie de ces
énièmes enfin c'est une énième loi de
sécurité fait à la va vite sous la
pression d'événements malheureux donc
sur les drones en l'espèce et sur les
questions qui sont posées aux drones
quand la cncdh s'inquiète en disant que
c'est un nouveau type de rapport entre
police et population caractérisée par la
défiance à la distance que c'est pas
seulement une nouvelle technologie de
surveillance
quand les magistrats les avocats les
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme des responsables éminent dit
cela je ne pense pas qu'il soit
farfelues et qu'il faille traiter sa
part le mépris donc nous considérons
selon l'endroit où on se trouve que ces
mesures sont prématurées inquiétante
voire dangereuse donc moi je pense que
l'amendement déposé par notre collègue
gontard méritent toute votre orientation
merci madame sophie playe polian pour
explication de vote
oui merci madame la présidente monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues je crois
qu'on peut dire beaucoup de choses on
peut utiliser des grands mots mais je
pense qu'aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas
dire avec les images qu'on a vu peu
tente lacéré de chaussures volée que les
migrants que les réfugiés sont
accueillis dignement dans notre pays
c'est pas vrai et malheureusement
beaucoup de françaises et de français
dans leur environnement quotidien quand
ils ont à côté de chez eux des
installations de fortune peuvent en
témoigner
donc aujourd'hui y compris à la
frontière on ne peut pas dire que les
gens sont accueillis dignement et ce
n'est pas parce que il ya quand même
dans notre pays est heureusement un
traitement des demandes d'asile qui
réalisait et des demandes d'asile qui
sont octroyés
on peut pas se cacher derrière ça pour
dire que les choses se passent bien
parce que je crois moi qu'on demande un
certain nombre d'agents de forces de
l'ordre on leur demande je pense pas
qu'ils le fassent de même de faire des
choses pour décourager décourager et
rendre les conditions de vie de plus en
plus difficile aux réfugiés et aux
d'ailleurs on organise d'ailleurs le
fait aussi que certains endroits des
journalistes n'est pas le droit n'est
pas la possibilité de venir observer
venir au revoir alors oui nous
parlementaires on est obligé de faire
notre travail c'est à dire d'aller
observer ce qui se passe
contrôler l'action du gouvernement et je
crois qu'aujourd'hui la situation elle
et elle est terrible parce que non
seulement elle met des réfugiés qui ont
déjà connu des souffrances extrêmes dans
des situations qui ne sont pas dignes de
notre pays et des valeurs qu'ils portent
mais en plus on mais aussi des agents
des forces de l'ordre dans les
situations de faire des choses que pour
beaucoup d'entre eux et d'entre elles il
réprouve
donc on peut pas dire que les choses
vont bien on peut pas dire que la france
est formidable on peut pas dire que la
situation des réfugiés magnifique et
lille
et que tout peut pas bien vraiment là je
crois que c'est nous qui vous le disons
on ne pouvait pas dire ça si cher
collègue madame gatel pour explication
de vote
merci madame la présidente cela me
servira d'explications de vote pour
l'ensemble de l'arctique avec beaucoup
de respect pour chacun je voudrais
relier ce qui se dit aujourd'hui au
débat qui nous avons eu hier sur les
drones et la liberté de manifester
d'abord je voudrais dire sans vous
provoquez chers collègues bien que vous
allez le prendre pour tel moi je ne
dirai jamais que vous dites n'importe
quoi je dis juste que parfois les propos
sont extravagants et ils peuvent être
hors sujet s'il ya une
instrumentalisation
aujourd'hui deux dispositifs qui doivent
veiller à la sécurité à la fois des
forces de l'ordre mais aussi de nos
libertés qui me semble prendre un
tournant dangereux et que je crois qu'il
faut ici parce que nous sommes tous
responsables
reconnaître l'exigence d'une évolution
des moyens de la sécurité pour garantir
nos libertés et madame la présidente à
ça si moi j'étais très touché parce que
vous avez dit hier et l'expression que
vous avez exprimé de votre volonté de
citoyenne de pouvoir manifester pour
exprimer vos idées et je salue ce que
vous avez dit et je salue votre
engagement et en même temps madame la
présidente
et j'ai entendu d'autres propos qui
m'ont profondément choqué hier
je pense que si on veut que chacun
puisse aller manifester pour défendre
ses idées dans notre démocratie
je crois que nous avons besoin d'une
sécurité qui permettent aussi à des gens
parfois d'aller manifester comme vous
l'avez dit
avec leurs enfants en toute tranquillité
et a tant entendu parler hier des
hélicoptères qui survolaient les
manifestations dans les villes
as tu entendu parlé hier de
manifestations qui étaient
instrumentalisés par des gens qui n'ont
qu'une envie c'est utiliser la liberté
la conviction de ceux qui vont
manifester pour aller détruire moi je
les ai vécus à rennes pendant des mois
parce qu'il y avait des gens qui étaient
là
utilisant la liberté pour détruire il
sincèrement je pense que notre
commission a veillé à sécuriser les
choses
et sincèrement je pense qu'il faut que
nous soyons réalistes et que nous
dépassions toute posture qui nous mène
très grosses difficultés par rapport aux
attentes de nos concitoyens et des
policiers qui nous protège merci chers
collègues je mets donc aux voix
l'amendement 133 avec deux avis
défavorables qui votent pour qu'ils
votent contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté nous passons à un amendement
et deux sous amendement l'amendement 188
rectifiée présentée par mathieu darnaud
oui mais la présidente
c'est un amendement de notre collègue
cédric perrin qui a pour objectif de
renforcer les outils utilisés pour
assurer la protection des installations
militaires et des installations
d'importance vitale en définissant les
conditions de mise en oeuvre des caméras
installées sur des aéronefs circulant
sans personne à bord
il est proposé à titre à ce titre pardon
d'insérer de nouvelles dispositions dans
les partis 1une et 2 du code de la
défense pour compléter le régime
juridique des installations d'importance
vitale et des installations militaires
ces caméras seront utilisés à des fins
de protection des zones militaires et
des établissements installations et
ouvrages d'importance vitale dans ces
conditions des garanties propres à ces
usages sont définis tenant notamment à
une durée de conservation des
enregistrements limiter à une
information générale du public
les traitements de données mise en
oeuvre devront également respecter
l'ensemble des garanties de la loi
informatique et libertés en particulier
dans son article 31 ces traitements
seront
si soumis à l'avis de la cnil l'acteur
réglementaire les autorisant déterminera
outre la durée de conservation prévu par
les nouveaux articles en cause les
catégories des données traitées les
destinataires de ces données et les
maudites les modalités pardon d'exercice
des droits reconnus aux personnes
concernées par ces traitements vous
remercie si chers collègues le
sous-amendement numéro 380 3 présenté
par monsieur richard hill la présidente
je rejoins pleinement les objectifs et
le cadre fixé par l'amendement de
monsieur cédric perrin et simplement en
regardant la les conditions de
fonctionnement et de protection de
certaines des unités militaires ou de
certaines bases militaires il se produit
aussi qu' une partie des images soient
prises paris kopter et par conséquent il
me semble que dans les deux alinéas
hausse est mentionnée dans le texte de
cédric perrin il faut retirer expression
de circulant sans personne à bord
puisque s'agissant du statut des images
et de la protection des tiers notamment
quant à l'utilisation de ces images les
images prises par hélicoptère dans ces
espaces là dans ces circonstances là
doivent être traités comme des images de
drones si le sous-amendement 374
présenté par le rapporteur
c'est daubresse dans la cohérence de ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure nous loïc
hervé a défini une doctrine d'emploi et
donc là nous mettons les garanties
nécessaires pour que ça se passe dans
les conditions de cette doctrine
d'emploi moyennant quoi nous sommes
favorable à l'amendement présenté par
mathieu darnaud est tout à fait
pertinent j'en profite pour rebondir sur
le débat précédent moi j'étais
rapporteur de la loi antiterroriste je
suis allé sur place dans les
alpes-maritimes et j'ai constaté qu'ils
avaient une importance vitale à ce qu'on
puisse sûr mais la frontière et nous
avons pu arrêter pas nous mais la police
a pu arrêter un terroriste dangereux
qu'ils s'apprêtaient à me lasser une
installation stratégique à dakar et qui
venait de parcourir des kilomètres le
long du littoral
et c'est évidemment par des changes à
type drone ou hélicoptère qu'on peut
arriver à surveiller sont deux choses
donc faut savoir ce qu'on veut
ce qu'on va être protégés éviter et
faire une vraie lutte antiterroriste ou
pas ce qui n'a rien à voir avec
l'accueil des réfugiés qui est un autre
sujet voilà donc avis favorable à
l'amendement de monsieur d'arnaud sous
réserve des sous-amendements est
favorable bien sûr à l'amendement de
monsieur richard très bien monsieur
ministre position identique sur les sous
un moment et donc sur l'amendement ainsi
amendé je mets donc aux voix avec deux
avis favorable à l'amendement numéro 3
le sous-amendement pardon numéro 3 183
de monsieur richard qui votent pour
contre il est adopté je mise aux voix
l'amendement 374 de sous-amendements 374
avec deux avis favorables qui est pour
contre il est adopté je mets donc aux
voix l'amendement ainsi modifié 188
rectifier avec deux avis favorables qui
est pour contre il est adopté
nous passons au lendement dont 328
rectifié bis monsieur richard remes la
présidente
il s'agit de des conditions
d'utilisation là encore d'image
aéroportée en matière de protection
civile et donc ce que je suggère c'est
le clarifier de resserrer les finalités
pour lesquelles ces images peuvent être
utilisés qui sont la prévention
l'évaluation des risques
le secours d'urgence aux personnes et la
lutte contre les incendies et accidents
se rapporte à votre avis alors je
préfère avec mathieu richard
s'il le veut bien retire son amendement
parce que la commission a défini un
certain nombre de conditions il pense
qu'il faut préciser élections je pense
qu'on pourrait tout à fait le faire en
cmp messieurs le sénat monsieur le
ministre est donc si vous en êtes
d'accord je m'engage à ce qu'on puisse
aboutir pour tenir prendre vos
observations très bien je mets donc aux
voix l'article 22 ainsi modifié qui et
pour qui et contre qui s'abstient
l'article 22 est adopté
[Musique]